foreign
sounds fun but then 47 [__] rocks
fall over onto your little toe and then
that little piggy can no longer go to
the market because you're sidestepping
your way down the street and everyone
thinks you're doing a terrible at grimly
impersonation it's in miles west of
Boston 10 miles west of Boston don't
underestimate the power of shrooms
people took them 20 years but they
managed to move Canada all the way to 10
miles west of Boston how much longer
five hour hike we can manage that saying
this with knees under the age of 30 to
someone with knees over the age of 30.
we're only three episodes in and I feel
like we've already used our walking
walking walking excitements in as far as
it can go in fact I'm less irritated
about them walking all the time in this
series and more irritated that you've
now made me sick of looking at reading
and writing a long-standing sin you're
causing me to send my own [__] sins
The Last of Us and I do not like it but
also walking walking
excitement happy now I said good day
what are you looking out for living in a
world that's 20 years deep into the
apocalypse and asking dumbass questions
like this when mushrooms have taken over
people's brains and are using humans to
eat other humans you are always on the
lookout I think there's a scar on your
head someone shot at me in this see
that's cool tell me you've never been
shot at without telling me you've never
been shot at no way I had a friend who
knew everything about this game I'm
really glad Ellie has these fun memories
to hold on to and didn't end up losing
that friend extremely tragically I'm
sure if that had happened this arcade
machine would be far more triggering for
her is there anything bad in here just
you ah getting funnier he is not sure
let's open the nope door and have a peek
inside it all the nopeness how was Ellie
survived to 14 does she actually have
the ability to respawn
convenient feminine product is
convenient although your body needing to
eject parts of itself each month is
extremely inconvenient so maybe this
balance is out let's just send periods
I'm not sure if this is a sin for
curious kids being stupidly curious or
if we should say Nellie's obvious
Beginnings to her future as a serial
killer let's just ding it twice to be
safe Ellie
show goes for the oh she really is in
trouble tension paws as if there's a
chance that creative license could
extend to killing off Ellie in episode
three how did it even start if you have
to get bit to be infected then who bit
the first person I thought you went to
school yeah but they only taught her the
stuff that doesn't need to be exposited
to the audience at some point was it a
monkey I bet it was a monkey why do you
have to immediately jump to monkey zelly
not every disease has been caused by a
monkey but also [__] monkeys they're
mean and they throw their [__] at you
cordyceps mutated
so they got into the food supply you eat
enough of it it'll get you infected so
the tainted food all hits the store
shelves around the same time Thursday
but like everywhere
all at once last episode we discovered
that the woman from the factory in
Jakarta went fungicidal Maniac on
Tuesday 23rd September and that was the
first recorded infected so what we're
saying is that by two days later the
flower from that factory was somehow
distributed to all the different brands
was turned into bread and pancake mix
and whatever was sent overseas to
America and Beyond and arrived at
hundreds if not thousands of stores
simultaneously oh and regardless of
delivery days all the products across
the country made it onto the shelves so
that by Friday enough people were
infected to hit a point of no return
this is unbelievably quick unbelievable
and the moral don't put dates in your TV
show there's stuff up there you
shouldn't see
now I have to see kids
no I know we're assuming physical harm
here but the mental trauma of witnessing
a mass grave really should be implied
here too
brutal honesty is one of Joel's Greatest
qualities and why we all love him Ellie
should be grateful that he would never
hide a life-changing secret from her
even if the whole world's survival
depended on it right we don't have a
date for when fedro was established but
this is four days after the outbreak and
they have signage created qz set up and
are executing people at will given the
organizational problems we experience
with our actual pandemic I'm calling
shenanigans on anything with fed in the
title pulling this off also prequels
positioning a camera in a way that
results in your god-given right to
defend your property being obstructed by
your god-given right to display your
patriotism you know what looking around
at all the guns and ammo in this room
really didn't give me enough context for
the number of guns and ammo this
character has so thank goodness for this
guns and ammo magazine so I can really
understand how much he likes guns and
ammo guns and ammo 10 Last of Us Lane
the most unbelievable aspect of this
entire episode is that all the wine is
still there and hasn't been stolen by
the military if you had a way to cut the
lock then why did he risk damage to his
vehicle with the other fence scene does
not contain my mouth eating this steak
you might assume the sin here would be
for over four minutes of showing us
Bill's survivalisting his way through
the apocalypse but you'd be wrong the
actual sin is assuming that we didn't
want to see the full four years I'm
really confused as to how Frank managed
to fall into this hole it's not even
covered and seems to be the only one in
sight to be honest I can barely see how
it would trap an infected why did Bill
miss the perfect opportunity to build a
moat believing that asking this question
will prevent me from sinning the absence
of an explanation if I feed you then
every bone you talk to about it is going
to show up here looking for a free lunch
and this is not an Arby's well Harvest
didn't have free lunch was a restaurant
Frank would be employee of the month at
TV sins bill goes from get the [__] off
my lawn to here take a shower while I
prepare this Michelin star gourmet meal
with red wine pairing I know the power
of boners is strong but why didn't bill
just send him off with a sandwich and a
canteen there is more if I can't I want
to believe me but
I don't know on BS on the man that
hasn't eaten for two days being full up
on this kind of a serving the position
of the food on Frank's plate moves
between shots and yes that is how picky
I have to be to sit in this master class
of Storytelling so I guess I'll be going
then I know he ends up not kicking Frank
out but if Bill at any point thought
Frank would have to leave and walk all
the way to Boston why would he serve him
all this wine friends don't let friends
hike in infected walking areas while
drunk kids it's an important lesson to
learn before the next apocalypse you
know how much these are worth currently
nothing and now it's Bill's turn to be
excellent at TV sins we usually just do
one of these per video but some bastard
is limiting how many sin removals I'm
going to be allowed to give and this
basically counts as one rummaging
through another man's piano bench
without his explicit consent love will
abide I'm very glad we get to see the
bill Frank relationship play out it's
truly beautiful but Frank picking the
one song out of all those music books
that would hit Bill's heart the most is
still some convenient [__]
who's the girl girl you're singing about
there is no girl
I know if you'd have told me that Nick
Offerman butchering a song by Linda
Ronstadt followed by this exchange would
be the most emotional scene of 21st
Century television to date and that it
would be in a damn video game adaptation
I would I would well I wouldn't believe
you okay at least I can't get any more
emotional from here but also emotions
and emotions will always get a skip wait
where's my skip ding what's that City
you love this episode so much that
you're refusing to skip anything and I'm
just gonna have to grow the [__] up and
deal with my emotions
all right then I guess for now I'll just
send that I'm not either of the Beards
in this scene what's your name Bill
doggy dog
skipping three years and assuming once
again that I don't want an entire
multi-season TV show following Bill and
Frank Playing House in the apocalypse
the boutique
are we hosting formal Garden parties now
I don't know why Frank has to be so
dismissive about formal Garden parties
they're so fun especially if they have
the little sandwiches I love little
sandwiches because they're little and
you can eat 30 of them and it's like
you're only eating 27 sandwiches it's
Heaven oh and I have this idea that we
should uh we should use codes for the
radio out of all the Mysteries that have
been presented to us over the last
couple of episodes the how did they come
up with the secret music codes wouldn't
have even made my secondary list of
things I needed to know but here we are
pick it up
like
I can't just one more loop around nope
not buying it I refuse to believe any
relationship survives coerced jogging no
I'm from the strawberries still not
having sex on top of strawberries till
you've tried it guys it's magical unless
of course you're allergic to
strawberries or hate to get sticky or
you know what just don't have sex on top
of strawberries
hold your hand there yes put your
unsanitized hand over an open wound does
anyone in these situations ever think
about the dangers of infections leave
the gas on here the fence defense will
kill the rest of them if that's true why
the [__] were you insisting on staying
outside with a belly full of lead
poisoning or better still why did you go
out there in the first place
married then you will crush all of these
up
put them in my wine then you take me by
my hand bring me to our bed
and I will fall asleep in your arms
freshly picked strawberries this is
supposed to be about zombies and how
dare you make me feel my own feelings
damn you Offerman damn you mazzin damn
you truck man do you love me yes they
love me the way I want you to
okay okay pull it together I can do this
uh the pick the picture on the wall is
wonky oh it looks like it was drawn by a
child the plant pot is a trip hazard
oh look it's the meat cute death trap
also it's been like 16 years since they
met in this hole and that's what the
grass looks like as Bill or Frank been
mowing it why don't the traps work
better if the grass is overgrown here's
a sin for all of Television the fact
that we are yet to have a
post-apocalyptic Anthology series that
actually focuses on human stories and
the Beautiful Moments that can be found
in the horror not fair on the episode
perhaps but that's what you get for
having the nerve to show us what's
possible I should be furious but from an
objective point of view it's incredibly
romantic sorry to crush the moment but
that's still pretty subjective to
whomever but probably Joel why would
they leave Tess's name off the envelope
it's as if they already know she's dead
which they should not that's why men
like you and me are here we have a job
to do I leave you all of my weapons and
equipment use them to keep he's dead how
is he still making me feel things Sandy
I'm begging you let me skip
Joel checks the fridge and finds the
battery Parts but why wouldn't Bill have
mentioned this needed instruction in his
letter that seems like a very important
item that was left out why is the music
on
reset the countdown every few weeks this
playlist would run over the radio
stealing from Lost in a universe where
lost never had a chance to exist I'm
taking a shower
getting this cozy in a house that has
two rotting corpses in the master
bedroom if you told me that the scene at
the piano would be topped in less than
30 minutes by several even more powerful
scenes well you wouldn't even be able to
hear what my thoughts were because I'd
still be a blubbering mess but it's
insane how perfect this episode is and
since and removals are the only way I
show affection here's another three is
an apology for not skipping directly to
episode four okay five but the next
episode had better really suck
we're struggling to understand the
physics of how this much roast beef is
ten dollars
this means something
now don't take this the wrong way but
you are a Terminator right yes Sabaton
systems model 101. I think my legs might
be broke
haven't eaten in two days a census taker
once tried to test me I ate his liver
with some fava beans and a nice Chianti
what's your name
Swanson
it is but a scratch